FR COMING UP.
>>> PLUS, JASEONO MORE COMING U
>>> FIRST,RIS
BUSINESSS WALLACE, T" VE
E ANNOUNCED IT ON
CS, TO ALLUSA FEW O.T MAY SOUND
.
ADY FOA NEW
AND I HOPE YOU'L>> THIS IS SHOCX
BECAUSE THE MORE AND MORT CALIZ
THE BIDEN YEARS.
WALLACE LAST SIGNEA COWITH FOX,.
I' ADI TS KN MATTER,
D OU OF HIS
CHGISOESTION, E MIGHE
GOING NEXT?
BRREL OUTLETWALLACE MAAN
LAUNCH EARNOT  AS I AMENT FROM
YOU KNOWBO W AT CHANGET FOX NEW.
BRIAN KLAAS, THOR TEOU STIKPUB
WHEN O
THDE PURGE PURGES.
AGCASE OE,LDURCE FOXANTED M TOY.
HE HOMETHING NAT SAY ABOND
RI
INNNCOMMENTATOR AND NATIONAL, W"
THANK YOU ALL FOBERE. ABOUT THE
TEIO AND AX NEWS
>> I DON'T THINK HHOOL YOU WASH
END RIGHT WINGNDE AT FOX.
I FEEL-
LIKE A CRAZY SAUCET YOU KE
R AND ITPSORE ANS  ME CONCAND AU
ORY OW
DEITH D HOW
UNSUSTFOX NEWS U LIK S S WAS
LOOK, WEE A WSNTSIDE BUT HNE
PEOPLE.
EXA  THEWSATHEE STARTECOAND
LL NEWS.
IGHT.
FTHAT WAS BAD.E ARTED KING
REKE CHRIS A S
ARVEOUT AND
SAY LOOK AONE LIKE
WALLACE AS EVIDENCE WE'RY BUTH
INDEG,
NTO AV
THNEW.ERY RE
POST" SAID W
HIS 1
MEUT, CHE AN
INTERNALLY, THEY WERE
HEORY STUFCOMING
AT TIME
HAPPENED AT FO SINT PROPAGANDA G
LIKEE SAID, CHRID ET BAIER AND .
CHRIWARVIV
LIDERS AE CHALM
THAT WAS A SERVICE FOR ALL
US, FRED
TLS DON'E ACCESS
TO SOME OF THESE REPUBLICAN
HE TIME.D CHRIS WA
THIS IS LIKEDAINGER,EY MOMENFOBN
PARTY.
FOR MODERATES?ISCEWHO WILLTHUM
LIKE HE SAN DOING
THIS F8 YEARS.
CREDIBLE
HAESS FOR WHAT HYOU HAVE TERTHRS
PLAYED A PART IN CAN -T.
FOMORAOOM S THERE
NALISTS?
CHS S IS THERE ROOM FO AT AS BRT
ATND
EXISTENTL
>> FOX SAYOSTS WIL
FILLSO EXPEC SEE
ROBERTAIL IN.
BUATNG OF
THAS
ENTERTAIED TO OUGRIER ABOUT
PRESID MAKE HATE
EN
COUPLE O WHAT' ON FOX
FOR JOE.VERY IS NO
WALK T, MBERING.DENT BIDEN DESP
ISNT.
>> WHAT HE'S DOINGLLINTHOMLIES.
>> PRICERGIN HIGHE
0 YEARS,INE
TOTAL CHAOD IO HERE WE'REA. SO O
THE HOUST ALL
ANS BEEND OF HIM ANDE WAIS TOO Y
THASE S S IS RUISAY,  WEL
PPT BUBBLE, IT IS
ID'S AWARE OF 'SY FALL FRIY NIV
.S HAENLE AFRAID.PEOPLE AREORRIU
HEM.
I DON'T MEAN ME BUT ABOU
THE SITUATION.
SO T TOLD THAT
H , ONOMY IS
GRN  AE
WE LOOK, ANGST IN AMERICA IALEN
ECON TURMOILLITICAL
BIDEN'S POLLING.FROM TAP
STL E AR
CONCERNED T IOANR ISSUES.
BUT HAT UE YESTH
AN BUTHIG
ARMAGEDDON'S ON THE
THE'A RTHAPPENININA
WEE PLAYG DON"
THE WO CR .
ALWAYS JPING TO TH
THE LATE V E,
YSE
F REAL
F  T
RNP INTO THE NIGHT
YES, THERE'S A BUM
HERE'S FNGHA
I'M DESCRIBI
GACES.
$7ACT. LINWA7 W IN CALIFORA
>> TO BE EL PRICE I.67.
SO IT'S QUITE  R,
ICES ARE A
BUT P SO EGREGIOUSLY
EXAGGERAS
IT INTO, A, SOME
KIND OF ARMADDON.
INACCURATE INFHINK
N IS RIGHT